welcome to the david pakman show i am
farin cousins from ring of fire with you
once again
to help close out what has been
quite a crazy week to put it mildly
so without further ado right let's just
jump right into today's story no need to
waste time let's get to it
big story happened this week the fbi
raided the homes of two individuals
involved in donald trump's fake elector
scheme those two individuals
uh brad carver who allegedly signed a
document to be a trump elector as well
as thomas lane who worked on trump's
effort to overturn the election in
arizona and new mexico
now as everybody i'm sure is aware the
doj is in fact investigating the fake
elector scheme
it's one of the few things from the
former trump administration that is
actually being investigated along with
of course the 15 boxes of documents that
were found down at mar-a-lago the doj is
also investigating that um with regard
to january 6 though
not so much we get more to that in just
a little bit but
this is a big one right we got a fake
elector we got a guy running donald
trump's you know day-to-day campaign
operations the fbi raided their homes
has seized some of their electronic
devices
and on top of that
other people also involved in the scheme
have received subpoenas
so here is what this means so far for
this investigation
it just means
that it's moving forward
i know that's a little disappointing i
know nobody ever just wants to hear that
the wheels are in motion right
we want action we we want meat we want
something of substance
that we can really sink our teeth into
and feel better
about these you know kind of slow
rolling investigations which let's be
clear that is what this is
yeah i saw a great analysis from a
writer this week that basically said
the doj is moving too slowly on this
particular story considering the fact
that this fake elector scheme didn't
just emerge on tuesday during those
hearings we've known about it for over a
year
and we're just now getting to the point
where okay well these are the fake
electors now let's go look at their
homes let's get their electronic devices
let's really start to
ramp things up a little bit i guess
whatever it is
it is too slow
but sometimes
sometimes
it's slow for a reason
other times
it's slow out of abundance of caution
and i'm afraid that that is the
situation that we are looking at right
now
the doj
led by of course attorney general
merrick garland doesn't want to give any
kind of appearance
that they are being overtly political
they want to make sure that they have
crossed their t's and dotted their eyes
before they make any moves on anyone
even some of these low level individuals
but even still
sometimes when you have the evidence you
don't need to sit on it you don't need
to wait
you don't need to hold off on issuing
subpoenas until the public is squarely
in your corner
sometimes you have to do something even
if it's unpopular if it is the right
thing to do
and i do believe that that of course is
the situation that we're looking at
right now with the fake elector scheme
i mean after all that is one of the
biggest things
obviously there is so much with january
6th and with the january 6 committee and
all of that that we could probably pop a
lot of people for a lot of different
crimes right away trump himself included
and again i'm going to get to that in
just a few moments
but
this fake elector scheme
this was the big gambit right they knew
that their court cases were losing they
knew they didn't have evidence of voter
fraud
but they pushed ahead with all of this
anyway
and in some states yeah they had people
ready to go
in michigan we found out this week that
their fake elector scheme because the
electors had to be in the state capital
uh to cast their votes so what they had
planned
which of course didn't come to fruition
but they had planned to somehow sneak
into the michigan state capitol
so that they would be present the
following day to be able to cast their
fake electoral college vote
i mean that is how deep this scheme went
i mean this truly is you know cross
country
you know north to south
south east to west all over the country
you had these little fake electors
willing to do whatever it took
to make donald trump the winner of the
election so thank goodness of course
that we do have the doj investigating
this
you know thank goodness we're seeing
some of these
positive step forward
individuals do need to be subpoenaed
they do need to you know if they're not
going to comply if we think they might
hide or destroy evidence they do have to
be rated that's how that works that's
why by the way that typically works in
that manner if you have an individual
you think could destroy evidence could
be hiding things
that's when you send the fbi in to go
try to find it
now over in georgia as well the fake
elector scheme has been gaining steam
and we have seen in recent weeks
several of the people who signed on to
be the fake electors not of course
necessarily
in a criminal way
and what i mean by that is you do have
some of the people who were the quote
fake electors in georgia
that are fully cooperating with the
investigators because they said listen
i was approached with this and they said
if these court cases
overturn everything for donald trump
we're going to need our electors are you
willing to do that and so you had plenty
of people in the state of georgia these
republicans who said oh yeah i'll do it
if if and only if
these court cases overturn the election
i'm here ready to go
and then once the court case is lost
these people said all right i'm out i'm
not going to do this
and those people have been working with
these investigators both in georgia and
the feds
and more importantly they've been giving
them names
they said listen i'm more than willing
to talk to you but i'm probably not the
guy you need you need you know this
person this person and this person the
names have not been released
so they are getting better leads and the
more leads you get
the longer the investigation takes the
more people you have to question the
more people you have to subpoena and of
course you have to go to the courts to
get the subpoenas
so maybe it's being slow rolled out of
that abundance of caution
which i do believe is the driving factor
but it also could be
that there's just so
many different leads
so many different states so many
different players
that this investigation kind of has to
go slow
because you don't want to miss anyone
and sometimes in our impatience and i'll
admit i'm probably public enemy number
one on that
sometimes we forget about that
you know we all want this kind of
instant gratification with these
investigations and unfortunately
that's just not the way it works so we
do have to be patient
we do have to let the process play
itself out because there are far too
many players here
for us to
even omit ignore or forget
a single one of them
having said that
i want to talk a little bit more about
my impatience because i do have a lot of
impatience right now
and nearly all of it is directed at
attorney general merrick garland
merrick garland as a.g as the top law
enforcement official here in the united
states
has so far
not
gone after donald trump in any kind of
meaningful way
sure the fake elector investigation is
obviously leading up to trump it has to
i mean he's the guy at the top of it
but we have had plenty of people
including those serving on the january 6
committee by the way so this isn't just
me being impatient this is also people
on the committee saying
hi
we've got all of this wonderful material
for you
could you do something
and what has been merrick garland's
response well as he told us last week
i'm watching the hearings
i'm watching them
we're paying attention
so the attorney general of the united
states is out there telling us like
don't worry folks i'm tuning in to cnn
every day just like you
no no no that's that's not good merrick
i don't want you to be learning this
stuff the same way that i am
okay again you're the attorney general
you you should probably i don't know
maybe be present in the room
i mean i'm sure they'd be willing to
give you a pass to go sit in the room
while they're doing the hearings
and if not you probably know somebody
that could get you one
you know we don't want the attorney
general
to sit there and say ah don't worry
folks i'm watching tv just like the rest
of you
well that's wonderful if we're
talking about the season of miss marvel
that's currently on but
we're talking about the january 6
committee hearings
you should already know what's happening
there should be sharing of information
maybe that's on garland maybe that's on
the committee but the bottom line is
that they have already and the judges of
course have confirmed this and we've
talked about it david's talked about it
everybody's talked about it
the judges who've looked at this have
already said there's evidence of
criminal behavior here right now
right now we have it we've got it
but merrick garland so far has not
opened up a single investigation into
donald trump himself for his actions
here
and that is
forever frustrating
and to me there there's no excuse for
that
no excuse
the january six committee
is only going to be able to continue
doing their job for a couple more months
eventually they will have to kind of put
it on pause so they can all go and
campaign
i mean
they're in the house they all have to
campaign except for the the you know
folks that aren't running anymore and
they're leaving after this so they're
gone anyway
and republicans unfortunately are poised
to take back over the house of
representatives they've made it clear
they do that committee's over with
so what garland should do and i know i
pitched this i think the last time i i
guest hosted on david's show here back
in december but merrick garland should
have already appointed a special
prosecutor
that's all you need
you give them the time you give them the
budget you give them the funds you give
them whatever they need but most
importantly you give it
time
because the january 6 committee does not
have time the january 6 committee has
wasted so much time having to go to
court
to battle these people who don't want to
comply with the subpoenas a special
prosecutor wouldn't have that problem
right a grand jury wouldn't have that
problem
it would be so much easier for a special
prosecutor to be appointed by merrick
garland to walk into that january 6
committee and say listen you guys have
done phenomenal work
i'm going to take it from here
thank you for everything you've done
thank you for everything you've given us
but i've got this don't worry
and in fact appoint two or three special
prosecutors there's a bunch of different
avenues bunch of different schemes that
do need to be investigated and it'd be
great to have a separate person on each
and every one of them
folks i've been screaming about that for
eight nine months now
and we still haven't gotten it
and the only person standing in the way
of that
is of course unfortunately
the attorney general of the united
states
merrick
garland
we cannot have any
any
forward progress
without his say-so
and finally real quick here
i do want to
mention one other story that happened
this week because i found this just
absolutely fascinating and that is of
course the fact that mo brooks
the now lame duck republican member of
congress because he lost his uh runoff
election this week to katie britt
came out
shortly after losing that election and
said you know what
i think i'm ready
to sit down with the january 6 committee
now
now he had previously been subpoenaed
however he had not been served his
subpoena because he was back home and
campaigning trying to win the race that
he ultimately lost
but the timing of that sure is
interesting isn't it
now that the dust has settled now that
he knows his political career is at
least at a temporary end
now he says i'll go ahead and talk to
you
now of course he does have some
stipulations here's what he says he says
my basic requirement is it be in public
so the public can see it so they don't
get bits and pieces dribbled out fine
i'm good with that
he also wants to see the material they
have on him and the questions that
they're going to be asking ahead of time
okay
i'll give you that as well
but i do not think it is a coincidence
that he has finally agreed to talk to
this committee that of course is clearly
going after donald trump
after he lost his election
possibly because donald trump pulled his
endorsement from him
i think mo brooks is out for revenge
and i think mo brooks understands that
the best way to get that revenge on
donald trump is to go sit down with that
committee and tell them everything they
know
mo brooks of course as everybody
remembers is the guy that wore the
bulletproof vest to go speak at the stop
the steel rally
it has also been reported
he says it's not true but it has been
reported
that members of his staff were actually
working with the stop the steel
organizers to help put the whole thing
together
so mo brooks has some things to tell
there's no doubt about that mo brooks
has some stories to tell
and i hope that he gets the chance to
tell them now ordinarily i would not
be in favor of the committee giving in
to his demands right you've subpoenaed
him you don't have to give into anything
but
if it means getting dirt on trump that
we otherwise might not get because
brooks wants to challenge it in court or
whatever he may choose to do
i say give in
put him on tv put it back in prime time
and let everybody hear what little mo
brooks has to say
about donald trump the man who screwed
him over
in his quest to be a united states
senator
we have to take a quick break but you
can get more from me on my youtube
channels check me out at youtube.com
slash the ring of fire and youtube.com
fair and balanced i'm farin cousins in
for david pakman and we'll be back with
more
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today and
if you want you can follow me across
social media twitter facebook and
instagram i'm at fahren
balanced i would appreciate any follows
you may throw my way but until then
let's get back to some more of the
biggest stories of this week and one of
the more grotesque things that we saw
happen this week in addition to marjory
taylor green's week-long meltdown
she took a minor break from that
to tell a british reporter
go back to your country
now we have the clip i'm gonna show you
in just a minute but before i do let me
go ahead and set up the uh you know set
the stage for you if i might
what happened here is that republicans
in the senate worked with the democrats
they came up with their bipartisan gun
control legislation
long overdue decades overdue really
and finally we got it not quite as
strong as we needed it but hey we got
something and sometimes you got to
celebrate even the smallest victories
even if it's not what you wanted you got
to take the wins when you can get them
but marjorie taylor green was angry
angry my friends angry
that those senate republicans dared to
join with those democrats
and take away your guns as she says
so she holds a press conference with a
couple of other uh weirdos
from congress including of course lauren
bobert thomas massey and andrew clyde
when she was confronted by a british
reporter and then this exchange took
place here it is
and it's our job to defend the second
amendment yeah if i understand that we
don't have guns in the uk that is true
but we don't have mass shootings either
children aren't scared to go you have
mass stabbings lady you have all kinds
of murder and you've got lost nothing at
the same rate well you can go back to
your country and and worry about your no
guns
we like ours here
go back to your country
you have mass stabbings lady
okay but
not
really
certainly not at the level that we see
mass shootings here in the united states
even before
we had the big string of mass shootings
taking place in america in may even
before that
statistics already showed us that we
were averaging here in this country 10
mass shootings per week
little more than one per day
and that of course is a mass shooting
defined as any single shooter event in
which four or more people are shot
more than one per day here in the united
states um
great britain is not suffering a mass
stabbing
every day
i i don't even know if they're suffering
a mass stabbing every
you know four months
as marjorie taylor green wants to make
it seem
the homicide rate here in the united
states is four times higher
than over in great britain
four times higher
and 80
of those homicides
guns
that's what's killing people 80 of the
time here in the united states when some
person kills another one
guns
that's the difference
mass stabbings
are not something that people in the
united kingdom walk around terrified of
every single day
versus here in the united states you're
not safe in a grocery store our kids
aren't safe in school you're not safe in
a house of worship you're not safe at a
music festival
you're not safe at a mall
you're not safe walking down the street
you're not safe
plain and simple you're not safe
here in the united states from gun
violence
it doesn't matter where you are where
you live red state blue state
yes some states do have higher rates of
course
but you go over to the uk
you don't see people cowering in fear
all the time
you don't see them out there saying the
only thing that stops a bad guy with a
knife is a good guy with a knife
they don't come up with those idiotic
talking points
but we do here in the united states
partly because we have elected officials
like marjorie taylor green
who rather than address the facts
rather than acknowledge
that this is a uniquely american
phenomenon because it is
she would rather insult that reporter
telling her go
back to your country
i mean we have seen obviously
these hardcore hate mongers
across the united states
i mean for centuries telling people go
back to your country
but here we have in the year 2022
an elected member of congress
telling another human being go back to
your country
are we even redeemable
as a society are we redeemable
as a country
if this is what we've got representing
us this is now the global face
of the united states and it really is
you know i i get emails i get comments i
get all kinds of things from people all
over the world
that talk about marjorie taylor green
that talk about lauren bobert or matt
gates or of course donald trump
the rest of the world does see these
things
and this is the face that we put forward
and i know this is just one individual
from a tiny little
county in georgia
who has somehow become the crazy global
face of what the united states is all
about and it all goes back to comments
like that telling a reporter
go back
to your country
and while we're on the subject of guns
we obviously
have a big one this week
the united states supreme court in
addition
to uh curtailing miranda rights here in
the united states saying that you can no
longer sue police officers for violating
your miranda rights which basically
means they don't exist anymore
they also issued a six to three ruling
along party lines which is how every
ruling is going to be i guess from now
on
striking down a new york state
concealed carry law
and here's what this law did
this law
said that you could only get a concealed
carry permit in the state of new york if
you were able to show a need
to have a concealed gun on you at all
times
well
gun rights advocates sued
this legislation by the way has been in
place for decades upon decades upon
decades i think almost 100 years
and the supreme court says you know what
you're right
there are no limits
on the second amendment
so you can't tell people that they have
to have a reason
to need a concealed carry permit nope
let's take it back
to the wild wild west which the wild
wild west by the way technically wasn't
even like that they actually had strict
gun control laws it's just an expression
that we use too many times i do as well
that really isn't even rooted in reality
but that's what the supreme court said
this week
here's the thing
most states
allow for concealed carry
the issue is
you have to have the permit
and of course the supreme court in their
majority opinion did say we're not
taking away the permit requirements
all we're doing is taking away the
requirement
for people who can even apply for a
permit
so
initially obviously when this ruling
came down
a lot of i don't want to call it
overreaction because we don't want more
guns in the streets more guns
statistically means more death we know
that that is the truth
but
it's not quite
as devastating i think
as everybody is kind of portraying it to
be because again new york state can
still still say okay you have to have a
concealed carry permit we have to know
everybody that is walking around
carrying a gun you have to apply for it
you have to pass the background checks
the fingerprint checks you have to you
know make it past the red flag laws if
you do all of that
then you can have your concealed carry
and even the conservatives on the
supreme court said that's okay
we're not taking that away
so
i i guess i guess that's a positive
i guess it's not as horrible
but it's still pretty freaking horrible
but this is what they do this is what
this extremist right-wing supreme court
does
no more miranda rights
no more row
and guns everywhere
that's the united states of america in
2022
but there's also plenty of room by the
way for hate good old-fashioned bigotry
as well
and
you want to find it
you need to look no further of course
than the modern republican party
this week republican senator roger
marshall from the state of kansas
announced that he's contemplating
blocking
an effort
a bipartisan effort in the senate
to fund school lunch programs across the
united states because
he's worried the biden administration
might use this as an opportunity
to not let states discriminate
against lgbtq
youth
let me read his statement as to why he's
currently on the fence
about feeding kids lunches at school
here he is
i'm just afraid that schools in kansas
won't have school lunches because of
this administration's radical view on
transgender issues and i'm afraid that
they're going to raid the school lunch
program over that issue
now seems a little confusing i
understand
here is what this idiot is confusing mr
marshall senator marshall i'll give him
that title senator marshall
believes that the usda's guidance
on who can receive funding which is of
course you got to make sure you do not
allow discrimination and bullying of
lgbtq youth in your school if you do
that if we find out you are in violation
we will take away your money the usda
says but only if you're receiving
federal money for nutritional programs
it does not apply
to the school lunch
program
so senator marshall isn't even talking
about the right
thing
but it doesn't matter right he didn't
take the five seconds that it would take
to understand that he has confused two
completely separate issues all he knows
is hey schools in kansas may be bullying
lgbtq kids and we don't want to lose our
lunches so nobody gets a lunch
you're going to tank this whole effort a
bipartisan effort by the way that
they're trying to ram through quickly
which is why you only need one objection
to stall it
they're trying to ram it through before
june 30th when the funding for the
current program expires
so senator marshall i guess would rather
see all kids go hungry
than have to see school districts not
allow
lgbtq youth to be bullied
in school
right let's just make everybody go
hungry
because we want to see kids
get
bullied
and again
it's all actually because he doesn't
even understand
that he is confused two completely
separate issues
hmm
what a party right
listen we gotta take another quick break
but if you want even more from me follow
me across social media twitter facebook
instagram at farren balanced and you can
find me on my youtube channels at
youtube.com slash the ring of fire
youtube.com fair and balanced i'm also
the host of the weekly ring of fire
podcast which you can find online at
rofpodcast.com
this is the david pakman show and we'll
be right back with more
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show welcome back to the david pakman
show i am fair and cousins from ring of
fire
once again filling in for david
you know one of the things
that we have talked about a lot with
regard to the january 6 hearing
is whether or not
any of these televised hearings are
going to have any kind of impact
on the 2022 midterm elections
and according to former tea party
republican joe walsh who tweeted out on
thursday
no
they will have absolutely no impact here
is joe walsh's tweet
twitter world may not understand this
but january 6 and these hearings won't
make any difference in the midterms the
hearings are important and necessary but
they'll have zero impact
this november
it's
kind of a bummer right
i mean
way to come along and ruin everybody's
mood there captain buzzkill
but at the same time
i don't completely disagree with him
i do think
for the most part
and i'm struggling to say that because i
don't know how much i believe him
or agree with him
but i do think he's right
if these things do end up having an
impact on the 2022 midterms
i don't think it's going to be
a hugely measurable impact
right it may affect like a couple races
but i don't think it's going to affect
enough of them
to
stop what we all see is likely coming
which of course is republicans taking
back the house i i don't see it doing
that i don't see enough momentum with
this
i don't see enough you know
tying it into the other republicans
because the hearings of course are all
really about donald trump and his
administration yes we've you know
identified several republican members of
congress that were involved
but even if we took out each and every
one of those people in the elections
republicans would still be poised to
take back the house so that is why i do
again kind of agree with what joe walsh
has to say
but then
the other but
is the poll numbers right
the poll numbers out there
are kind of contradicting it at least
right now
here's what they tell us nearly
two-thirds of us adults believe the
january 6 2021 riot at the capitol was
planned according to a new quinnipiac
poll poll found that 64 of respondents
believed the attack was planned and 30
believed it was spontaneous
okay
so it's influencing public opinion
which is great
i mean that that's the whole point of
all of this we want to influence public
opinion
but not because we're trying to
brainwash them or you know push them
into any kind of political ideology but
because we want to influence their
opinion on the people who perpetrated
these acts and there's a big difference
between those two
this is not a partisan political
committee as the republicans would like
to have you believe
this is in fact a fact-finding mission
and so far a lot of the facts that they
found have been very bad for the
republican party
so
the question is
could it
have an impact on the 2022 midterms in a
meaningful way and the answer is
possibly
in order however for that to happen
the committee's work
would have to focus more on the
republican party as a whole
you know not just paint donald trump and
and giuliani and some of these other
weird little characters out there as you
know the only people
they would have to come back in and tie
it all in saying this folks is who the
current republican party is
and that's not the job of the committee
that's the job
of the democratic party
and that's where that disconnect exists
the january 6 committee has done great
work
i was skeptical of them at first didn't
think they could pull it off they have
they have proven me wrong and i am
grateful to them for it
but now is the time for the democratic
party to step up
because yes these hearings are impactful
yes they are changing public opinion
but the committee is not going to sit
there especially with republican like
liz cheney sitting on there and say this
is who all republicans are they're not
going to do that and they shouldn't do
that either
they kind of should but they can't i
understand they absolutely cannot
because you will start to turn off
people
what the democratic party could do
should have already been doing
is turning some of this into ads
ads running on national television
channels all across the country
but they're not
the messaging
from the democratic party
needs to be that this is who the
republicans are not this is who trump is
not
this is who jim jordan is
this is who they all are
every one of them
yes use that language
yes i don't care if it makes liz cheney
or adam kinzinger sitting on that
committee angry
this is your opportunity
the public is paying attention to these
hearings millions of people have already
tuned in
the polls are shifting in pretty
significant ways i mean rather shocking
ways if you ask me
so seize that moment jump on that
opportunity
and put it in ads
put it in people's faces every day
tie every single republican candidate
out there
back to these people
because even if they didn't participate
they still vote with them
hell a lot of the candidates out there
running for office actually support what
happened that day they still support
donald trump
that's why you do have candidates by the
way like dr oz who have now shifted
their messaging to stop mentioning trump
as much
and you know moving back on to just just
the issues folks
don't let them do that don't let them
get the upper hand tie every republican
in the country
to everything this committee has found
you do that you may have a pretty
significant impact on the midterms
but if the democratic party is sitting
there waiting for the january 6
committee to do this themselves it ain't
going to happen
that is not the job of this committee
and if they attempted to do that they're
going to lose all the credibility that
they have
this is on the democratic party they
could
do this
they should do this
but
if history is any indicator
they uh
won't
be doing that
but i'll tell you
as i said the polls are shifting
shifting in pretty good ways right
and one of the biggest things that we're
seeing happening
is that people are flocking away from
donald trump as a result
of this january 6 you know the televised
hearings and everything
and one of the people
who is watching this happening
and seeing
how republicans are reacting
happens to be republican pollster frank
luntz
now frank luntz appeared on cnn
yesterday
and on cnn he was actually asked about
an issue i talked about yesterday ron
desantis beating donald trump in that
new new hampshire poll and here
is what mr luntz had to say about that
when asked if desantis is a threat to
trump he said quote
it's more than a threat
the governor is proving that his
approach and what he's trying to
accomplish and what he has accomplished
in florida is more significant and
republicans are now saying
it's time to move on
there's now polling out that shows that
donald trump is actually paying a price
for what these hearings
are showing
now
saying that the republican party is
ready to move on from donald trump based
on one poll from university in new
hampshire with just a few hundred people
in i don't know that i'm willing to say
that hey donald trump's out of the party
everybody's moving on
that's reading way too much into a
single way too early poll
however he's not wrong
about the other polls
here's one of my favorite things
prior to that very first televised
hearing two-thirds of people in this
country did not believe that donald
trump bore responsibility for what
happened on january 6th today
two-thirds of people in this country
believe that donald trump bears
responsibility for what happened on
january 6th
it literally flipped
it flipped
in two weeks folks two weeks that's
pretty impressive right
and that's the point
like that's how powerful these hearings
are
that's why all of this
matters
not just because we want to change
public opinion mostly obviously because
we want
justice
we want those people who broke the law
to pay the price
but i think we're all kidding ourselves
if we don't admit to at least a small
degree that there is some level of
vengeance in us that feels good about
this that wants it to tank his approval
rating which it has his approval rating
donald trump's has gone down since these
committee hearings began
that is of course what frank luntz is
referring to
people are tying donald trump directly
to this and as i said you've got
republican candidates dr oz is a great
one they're running away from him even
though trump came out and backed him
made him
you know had it not been for trump oz
probably wouldn't have won that primary
same thing with jd vance
i don't know if jd vance is running away
from the trump messaging
but other people are more and more
candidates
and it's not because donald trump is
still not an influential figure in the
party he is and he will remain an
influential figure in the party whether
they want him to or not he's there to
stay he's your monster
you get to keep him forever
but the voters out there
they're not so happy with it
and we're going to start to see i
promise you in the coming weeks we're
going to see more and more republicans
start to run away from him because like
lunt said
it's having a real impact on donald
trump it may not be affecting the rest
of the republican party
these hearings at least
but if they continue to try to tie
themselves to trump
it will come back to hurt them in the
midterms
we need to take another quick break i'm
fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman and we'll be
right back with more
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins have been sitting in
for david pakman and if you want more
from me you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com the ring of fire i'm also at
youtube.com slash farron balanced
let's get back into more of today's
stories before we wrap up today's show
now
donald trump has been out there publicly
blaming kevin mccarthy house minority
leader for even allowing these gosh darn
hearings to happen in the first place
and according to reports coming out
thursday it's actually steve bannon who
has been whispering into trump's ear
that kevin mccarthy is to blame for all
of this
and as trump this week has continued to
blast mccarthy in statements
and posts on his truth social
something rather extraordinary has
actually happened in the house of
representatives on the republican side
suddenly
you have all of these pro-trump
republicans
that have been coming out
and defending
kevin mccarthy
now before i get into their defenses
let's just mention real quick one of
donald trump's biggest gripes of course
is that kevin mccarthy allowed this to
happen he doesn't have any republicans
on the committee he's screwed up all of
this is a farce and it's all kevin
mccarthy's fault so let me read some
statements first one is from
representative kelly armstrong of north
dakota who says kevin made the only
decision he could
what are we going to do allow them to
just functionally silence entire
constituencies we don't get good hands
all the time in the minority
then jim jordan
who of course has actually been
implicated in the scandal jim jordan
kicked off the committee by nancy pelosi
and obviously for very good reason jim
jordan says
let's say kevin says i'm gonna give you
new names there would have been a
problem there i think she was always
going to wind up here because she wanted
the partisan show
okay
what about representative elise stefanik
what does she have to say well she says
i do think kevin has handled this
appropriately and the members support
how we've handled this
yikes
now typically when donald trump comes
out and attacks somebody
the rest of the republican party falls
in line and they say yeah this guy's
terrible
you know we don't like this woman either
whoever it is he's attacking they're
going to go after him
but when you have people who of course
are actually vying for kevin mccarthy's
spot
as potentially the next speaker of the
house people like stefanik people like
jim jordan who would love nothing more
than to be speaker of the house they're
coming out and defending him against the
attacks being leveled at him by donald
trump
that's a problem for trump
it absolutely is
your support
among the house is clearly not as strong
as you thought it was
and that's never a good thing for
somebody in a position like trump is in
to have to find out the hard way
now of course
it could all be for show
republicans right now have to basically
put out this united front they're
getting lambasted by this committee the
whole party looks terrible
so maybe they're just trying to put on a
brave face and try to stick together as
long as they have to and then after that
they're going to eat each other again
but
publicly coming out and refuting
what your big guy has to say
it's not a good look and i don't know
that trump's going to be happy about it
and speaking
of republicans who are in a bit of
trouble how about ron johnson right
republican senator ron johnson of course
has been implicated directly in the fake
elector scheme
and he promised us on thursday
that folks it's a total nothing burger
this whole thing is overblown what are
you all even talking about
ron johnson
of course wants the whole thing to blow
over because as i said he's implicating
the fake elector scheme he had his chief
of staff read reach out to pence's staff
said senator johnson's got something he
wants to hand deliver to mike pence that
hand delivery of course
was the slate of fake electors from
wisconsin possibly even michigan
actually as uh
as johnson has now said too so oops
[ __ ]
but here is what he said this one in the
statement he released on thursday
we are piecing this together you'll find
out what a nothing burger this is it's a
complete non-story it will all be clear
and you'll never have to ask me this
question again i'm going to give you
everything we know
this happened 18 months ago my staff's
involvement was over the course of
minutes my own personal involvement was
probably seconds
so yeah everybody just
chill out a little bit right
well no because we're talking about
subverting democracy
we're talking about potential violations
of the electoral vote act
we're talking about criminal conspiracy
possibly we're not just gonna relax
we're not just gonna say oh you're right
total nothing burger man
i didn't know what i was delivering in
this package to the mafia
yeah
that that excuse doesn't ever work for
anyone literally ever
ron
so again
as i've said the first time you came out
with your excuse and said oh no it was
just my staff who did this i didn't even
know what was in the package you may
want to work on that defense maybe want
to fine-tune it a bit
because there is a very good chance as
this moves forward
that you might have to be giving that
defense
in a court of
law and finally today
again a little bit more about these
hearings but i'm sorry folks it's the
biggest news in the country right now
fox news
fox news
has of course after they decided to not
air the first hearing and then lost a
bunch of viewers to other networks
decided they've got to start running
them and they have been
and here's what's remarkable you have
hosts on that
network that have finally started to
open their eyes and realize oh my god
this looks bad
neil cavuto has come out and admitted
this looks really bad for donald trump
and martha mccallum this week
said that it was quote stunning
that there was such an amazing lack of
evidence to any of donald trump's claims
of voter fraud let me read the statement
that she said on the air on fox news
this week
it will be extremely useful in coming
campaigns especially the presidential
when you look back at what we have in
terms of the mike pence part of all this
so it is a political discussion it is
very compelling and the lack of evidence
is the huge stunning clear moment here
where these people are saying look i
supported you
please give me something to work with
and it simply
doesn't materialize
now to be honest martha if you actually
watched any other network other than
your own you wouldn't be stunned by any
of it
like that's the funniest part of all
this she's like oh my god this is
stunning how there's no evidence no
no it's not
it's not stunning to any of us at all
that have been paying attention to this
because there's never been any evidence
even
when by the way
republicans have had the opportunity to
provide evidence they have failed to do
it i mean hell mike lindell
ceo of my pillow actually has another
little cyber symposium type thing coming
up in a couple weeks
where he says this time i'm going to
give you all the evidence all of it
every bit of it
oh really just like you promised us last
august just like you promised us
over the thanksgiving break you're
holding these cyber symposiums you swear
up and down you have all this evidence
and then gosh darn it when it comes down
to it you always just forget to give it
to us whoops right rudy giuliani same
thing claims to have all this evidence
heck the dude even claims to have the
contents of hunter biden's laptop or at
least he claimed at one point he did
nothing
nothing at all
huh
and martha mccallum is stunned by this
that there is no evidence to back any of
this up how are you even stunned okay
even if these people who claim to have
had it don't turn it over
how can you be stunned when we have had
recounts we have had audits we have had
signature verification we have had every
possible thing to look into every
possible election
and nothing materialized
none of this is stunning none of this is
shocking
all you had to do martha which i'm glad
you're doing it now but have been great
if you've done it a year and a half ago
all you had to do
was open your eyes
listen that's all the time we have for
today we have a wonderful uh members
bonus show coming up today lauren bobert
got a lot more trouble with her coming
up we also have jewel being banned by
the fda but hey if you want more from me
fair and cousins find me on youtube
youtube.com slash the ring of fire
youtube.com fair and balanced i'm on
twitter facebook and instagram at farron
balanced thank you so much for david for
letting me fill in bonus show coming up
shortly this is the david pakman show
thank you for watching
you